what have you found the most challenging
part about raising kids to be having my
own past and having made the mistakes
that I made that are pretty much public
information if I'm successful business
and failed being a father that's all for
nothing so I got to make sure that I
could be the example mark is from a
family of nine kids himself in his new
film he and his wife played by Rose
Byrne consider adopting a set of
siblings three kids too much oh my god
they're adorable there are so many great
kids looking for family Rose had her
second child just before they started
shooting and the movie made mark already
a father of four consider adoption in
real life do you think you really could
add to your family I don't make those
decisions that's my wife's call but I'm
just knowing her you can't help but
think about the fact that there are a
lot of kids out there that really need a
home
Octavia Spencer plays a social worker an
instant family off the set she showed up
for Mark's 4:00 a.m. workout club and
came to play I got phone calls from some
of like the biggest stars in town kind
of like you know I'm coming to the 4:00
a.m. Club I aspire to be better nobody
showed up she comes in and she kills it
and she you know what she's inspiring so
many other vehicle
[Applause]
you